bonsoir diagonale l'actualité
internationale du jeu d'échecs avec ce
soir donc on éviter tout à fait spéciale
oui alors puisque ce soir stéphane nous
recevons donc nicolas giffard pour sa
grande rentrée sur diagonale bonsoir
nicolas déjà venu donc sur les voies la
rencontre représentées puisqu'on a
maintenant deux nouveaux spectateurs et
téléspectateurs
donc nicolas giffard maître
international champion de france en 78
longtemps en 82 et écrivain de renom et
dans le monde des échecs avec plusieurs
livres à son actif
oui donc voilà donc tu reviens avec nous
aujourd'hui on voit qu'on l'avait grand
plaisir avec grand plaisir je crois au
système thèmes viennent diagonale ise
comme que j'adore nos petits
collectionneurs et est une pour faire un
mauvais jeu de mots d honneur et une
ligne ouverte où on peut aborder tous
les sujets intéressants des échecs alors
sujet intéressant aujourd'hui et loi
c'est ce championnat du monde toujours
de las vegas est la surprise de la
semaine un petit peu karpov attaque la
file et oui c'est pas vraiment une
surprise donc puisque karpov on se
doutait qu'il avait une carte dans sa
manche et donc ils attaquent la fidh et
il attaque le seuil où on s'est un peu
surprenant il n'a pas participé au
tournoi et maintenant ils réclament un
peu un match contre kalichman alors
pourquoi la bayerische dirais que c'est
pour l'argent c'est d'avoir tout à fait
particulier effectivement ils attaquent
la file et nicolas par l'intermédiaire
du seuil haut parce que la fille d
depuis juin est désormais reconnue par
le comité international olympique donc
car profond qui est sincère contre la
fidh et finalement oui c'est un peu un
combat d arrière-garde je pense parce
que karpov a prétendu que ce championnat
du monde n'était pas vraiment parce que
il
pas été organisées suivant les clauses
prévues mais en fait le championnat du
monde qu'il a gagné lui même a été
exactement sur le même modèle donc si
lui a été champion du monde on peut
considérer qualif man ne l'êtes aussi
avec l'année un match contre qualif man
qui n'était pas prévu apparemment c'est
je pense un procès perdu d'avancé pour
karpov
alors c'est pas aussi claires puisque
les
les atouts avancés par interpol les
atouts qu'il a dans sa manche c'est ça
l'enjeu serait donc un accord qui aurait
été signé après le précédent championnat
du monde qu'ils aient lieu à lausanne du
président de la fédération
internationale domino qui promettait que
le prochain championnat du monde aurait
lieu deux ans plus tard
ce qui hélas sont d'importance puisque
pendant deux ans on peut faire sautiller
un titre pendant deux ans c'est pas
pareil que de le faire fructifier
pendant 18 mois et notamment karpov
aurait en attendant b contracté des
possibilités de simultanée des
possibilités de tournois pendant l'été
qui n'étaient pas compatibles avec ce
championnat du monde
avancez en fait oui c'est ce qui prétend
bon ça va savoir mais je crois que il a
peu de chances de gagner son procès
parce que tout simplement les tribunaux
vont rarement dans les affaires internes
des fédérations sportives et en général
ils disent vous allez lui ce président
laver votre linge sale en famille
débrouillez vous entre vous c'est pas
notre problème en général c'est ça qui
c'est comme ça que ça se passe
et disons je vois pas comment il
pourrait forcer kalichman a joué contre
contre karpov puisque lui dans son
contrat on n'a rien signé du tout il a
joué pour le titre de champion du monde
alors pourquoi karpov pourquoi pas
kasparov one hand et maintenant il fait
kalichman est libre de gérer son titre
comme il lui semble alors le problème de
fond et wahaha c'est effectivement ce
nouveau changement de formule en fait
qui crée ce problème on peut peut-être
réexpliqué encore une fois le ce qui
vient de se passer ces deux dernières
années ce changement de concept du
championnat du monde d'échecs où ils
changement de concept avec le nouveau
président dont personne ne domine off
qui a mis des dollars sur la table pour
organiser tous les ans un championnat du
monde médiatique médiatique dans le sens
où c'est maintenant c'est un peu comme
au foot c'est la coupe du monde sans
joueurs au lieu de
au lieu de 8 en fait 100 joueurs qui
font des matches à élimination directe
ce qu'une système qui est bien mais être
bien meilleur à priori beaucoup plus de
deux résultats des matchs - l'ont donc
plus apte à être suivi par par la nasse
donc championnat championnat très
médiatique au fait
et puis des têtes de série qu'ils
tendent des têtes de série qui tu en
voilà beaucoup de beaucoup de surprises
et donc dans un match comme ça enfin
dans un tournoi comme ça où il faut
battre 5 fois un adversaire sans subir
une seule défaite
tout peut arriver et c'est ce qui est
arrivé ici kalichman à gagner alors
qu'on attendait plutôt les favoris par
exemple tram ni qui vont ciucci rohff
ils sont tous fait éliminer on a vu donc
kalichman qui gagne le tournoi
c'est un champion un peu exceptionnel
c'est pas on l'attendait pas disons et
maintenant il se retrouve valence et
14ème championnat donc la formule a des
défauts des avantages les avantages
c'est simple c'est plus médiatique c'est
plus joli il ya plus de résultats
sportifs et l'inconvénient c'est que
entre guillemets n'importe qui peut
devenir champion du monde
non je crois pour revenir à khalis munn
que c'est un joueur extrêmement fort
mais qui a le malheur de ne pas être je
veux dire dans les 30 premiers depuis
une dizaine d'années c'est un peu moins
se sont toujours un peu les mêmes 30
premiers joueurs du monde qui jouent
ensemble en amont 10 qui se partagent
leurs points hauts et les autres qui
sont juste un peu derrière n'ont pas la
chance de les affronter en fait et des
joueurs comme calife man comme of social
comme hakobian et bien n'ont jamais eu
finalement la possibilité de s'exprimer
alors que l'on sait très bien que sur
peu de parties en tout cas sur un match
je ne sais pas mais c'est long je ne
sais pas blessé avec la formule las
vegas sur deux parties ils peuvent
battre n'importe qui en fait nicolas
nous recevions là
il y a deux semaines la semaine dernière
ni me gally l'espace qui nous disait
quand même qu'il y avait il à jouer
contre copions il a joué contre le
califat il a aussi joué contre eux
kasparov
il ya un écart de niveau qui est énorme
en fait entre entre kasparov et un peu
le reste donc ça c'est aussi à c'est
aussi à considérer kasparov au
classement elo il a quand même 2850 soit
entre 100 et 150 points de plus que ses
poursuivants
non mais c'est évident que kasparov et
le meilleur joueur du monde mais je
pense d'ailleurs que s'il avait
participé à ce big ask il aurait quand
même gagné mais la formule s'est pas
risqué pour lui est de seulement deux
parties mais bon ce sont des joueurs
si on regarde par rapport je sais pas je
vais citer topalov ou des joueurs qui
vers la dizaine même short 12 10 15e
place mondiale sont pas tellement plus
fort que kalichman or il joue 4 9 fois
plus de nous dit fois plus de tournois
du top 2 en fin de tournoi de la grande
élite des échecs et top niveau le
kremlin des échecs que kelly fans mais
alors quelle formule proposée finalement
quelle forme proposée peut-être d'abord
on peut rappeler qu elle était
l'ancienne formule de ce championnat du
monde et quelles sont les formes eu
effectivement de ce tournoi où les
joueurs jouent entre final comment sarah
comment ça fonctionne alors l'ancienne
formule était
donc un système global mondial avec
d'abord des trois zones aux qui
regroupait plusieurs pays qui qualifier
trois ou quatre places selon la force
des zones
tous ces joueurs c'est en faisait à peu
près une centaine se regroupaient pour
jouer le tournoi interrégional et là on
prenait les dix premiers qui jouait en
match à élimination
tout ça pour désigner non pas le
champion du monde mais le challenger le
champion du monde étant bien assis faye
avait une phase de matchs des candidats
s'est désigné d'abord des candidats qui
faisait des matches éliminatoires a dit
ça c'est après l'alternance
les candidats début premier donc oui si
ça les huit candidats faisait des
matches entre eux pour désigner le
challenger du champion ensuite donc ce
joueur arrivé
exténué bout de deux ans à peu près
beaucoup deux ans après l'avoir dévoilé
toutes ses nouveautés pour arriver à se
qualifier
arrivé contre le champion du monde qui
lui bien tranquille regardez les parties
analysées chez lui était tout reposer il
y avait pas trop de tension nerveuse et
là il commence un match devint où 24
partis ou champions avait un avantage
énorme faut bien lire alors ça c'est
vrai qu'avec ce nouveau système la
justice ce malheur conservés dans la
mesure où tous les joueurs partent ego
et je pense aussi qu'il ya un phénomène
qui était un peu injuste à l'époque
c'est que le mandat de trois ans est
trop long quelqu'un comme petrosyan
quand il a gagné il était clair qu'il
n'était pas vraiment un supérieur aux
autres
les tournois dans les trois années le
prouvait il était rarement 1er mai il
était championne du monde pendant trois
ans ce qui est une éternité par rapport
à vrai niveau qu'il avait donc un ancien
système d'abord qui était aussi
effectivement très long on peut dire
aussi on parler d'eux
nicolas des surprises qui a eu de
surprise parce que classement elo -
henrik ont utilisé en fait ces joueurs
classés au delà de la 30e place mondiale
voire même la 10e puisque de plus en
plus c'est les dix premiers jouent entre
faisait ce qu'on appelle des tournois
fermé loi du vent ils font toute l'année
des tournois qu'on appelle faire mais
peut-être détaillé aussi cette formule
puisque ça joue aussi dans la
classification mondiale et donc un petit
peu les sarcasmes de kasparov qui dit
que ces joueurs là ce ne sont pas si
forts mais ils n'ont pas l'occasion de
jouer contre les autres pourquoi
à cause de ces tombes refermées oui
alors letton a fermé on les connaît
c'est linares dos hermanas dortmund
tous ces tournois d'un niveau très
relevé qui réunissent donc ce fait la
fameuse crème des échecs le top 10 ces
joueurs jouent entre eux donc il ya un
risque qui est moindre dans la mesure où
même si l'on 2700 ils vont jouer contre
une moyenne à peu près de 1700 donc ils
n'auront plus qu'à faire la moyenne
ils ont entre eux et sainte élimination
sans élimination bien sûr on vient pour
notre jeu on reste nos jours car tous
les joueurs jouent les uns contre les
autres et donc au final joue contre une
moyenne et l'eau qui est très très élevé
de toute façon donc il faut vraiment de
perdre beaucoup de points pour perdre
des points vous voyez alors et après on
tombe un peu dans le dans la masse pour
ainsi dire le bas de la pyramide
quand on se retrouve ex-aequo avec 40
autres personnes on n'est plus qualifié
pour ces fameux tournoi fermé du top 10
et là on se retrouve obligé de jouer des
tournois qu'on appelle open ou là à la
première ronde on joue pas 1 2700 juin
2002 sans suivi d'un de 1300 à 2400 et
ainsi de suite et là il faut marquer
huit points sur neuf donc l' open et
loire on n'est pas des plus disent on
est 100 200 voire 1000 comme aux
championnats de france à besançon est en
fait tout le monde va jouer de neuf
partis mais il n'ya pas que dix joueurs
y en a 1000 donc c
les joueurs quand le même nombre de
points ensuite qu'ils se rencontrent
entre eux le dernier prendrait un
exemple de l'injustice imploser tournoi
fermé qui regroupe toujours les mêmes
joueurs c'est celui de joël lautier
devait lautier à un score positif ou
encore contre kasparov
ouais tout à fond ça veut dire qu'il est
capable de battre n'importe qui que
c'est un joueur extrêmement
spectaculaire mais il fait très peu de
ces tournois là parce que son classement
elo qui est moins bon ferait tomber la
moyenne et loue des tournois or les
sordides histoires font une espèce de
surenchère pour avoir la meilleure
moyenne et l'eau c'est un peu stupide
qu'est-ce qu'on le dit ce qui est
intéressant dans un mouton assez les
partis qui sont je ne sais pas
et bien donc il est victime jallet côté
de ça il a eu le malheur de faire un ou
deux open qui nous fait perdre son
placement héros d'il ya trois ans mais
dépassé les 2650 je crois et donc voilà
c'était c'est complètement injuste mais
c'est comme ça une surenchère idiote
entre les opérateurs pour avoir la
meilleure moyenne et l'eau alors on
vient de détailler ses différentes
formes le championnat donc ce nouveau
type de championnat championnat du monde
donc maintenant par élimination directe
sur un mois avec 100 joueurs au départ
et des parties en deux jours on fait des
matches entre deux jours en deux parties
l'ancien système qui était beaucoup plus
long et où le nombre de partis en fait
de match était beaucoup plus lent et ne
désignait comme challenger qui est prêt
faisait une finale contre le tenant du
titre le sortant en fait et qui en plus
on perd deux matches nuls garder son
titre
autre avantage pour le champion avantage
pour le champion dernier système
enfin deux autres systèmes qu'on a vu de
tourments le tournoi fermé
d'ailleurs je crois il est nicolas tu
vas tu vas vous confirmer qu'il ya eu un
championnat du monde ottoman affirmé ah
oui après la guerre parce qu'il a fallu
le champion du monde était mort avec son
titre est allé keane en 46 et donc après
la guerre en 48 il a fallu y avait pas
un tenant du titre donc il a fallu
réunir un groupe de joueurs qui
disputent le titre
donc c'est donc un groupement de 10 été
vite je crois un dispositif est assez
bonne vie dit qu'il a gagné
voilà avec bronchtein avec tous alors là
donc ça c'est troisième type de tournoi
et quatre équipes dernier type de
tournois ces détournements de type open
donc là il ya une grosse masse de
joueurs et on joue tout le monde va
jouer neuf parties les joueurs ayant le
même nombre de points en jouant entre
eux à la fin évidemment il n'a plus que
quelques uns qui ont un maximum de
points par contre qu'un championnat du
monde de ce tournoi open de s'est
déroulée
non je crois pas il ya des championnats
nationaux qui se déroule comme ça comme
en angleterre par exemple l'espagne sion
peut-être en espagne mais au niveau
mondial non ça s'est jamais produit donc
voilà en fait l'inconvénient majeur du
loup tournoi open s'est il ya beaucoup
de mazères ne serait ce que dans
l'appareil mais on peut jouer un joueur
qui à 2300 équivaut 2004 semble et
inversement
c'est à dire que ça c'est un peu vrai la
tournée ali minatoires comme las vegas
et on peut voir là je pense aux
appareils tout à fait mais c'est ce
qu'on retrouve pas dans le temps de
faire mais justement on est on a fermé
tout le monde va jouer contre tout le
monde
donc là il n'y aura pas de pas trop de
hasard sinon maintenant je voulais
mentionner un autre type de temps à
stéphane scellés tournoi hybride un
petit peu ce qu'on a fait donc au
championnat de france à besançon
oui et également aux états unis il faut
sont en train de le faire en ce moment
tournoi alors avec des poules au départ
ensuite on prend les deux premiers ou
les quatre premiers comme on veut et on
les fait jouer entre eux de façon
croisée c'est à dire le deuxième des
quarts de finale
en fait exactement comme la coupe du
monde de football en fait voilà c'est
exactement ça c'est à l'ère des poules
tout le monde joue contre tout le monde
et ensuite les premiers sont qualifiés
pour faire des matchs éliminatoires
six hommes qui m'a l'air très très bon
enfin on a pu le vérifier à besançon
malgré quelques légers problèmes
je dirais qu'ils ont été résolus par les
américains jusqu en france on n'a pas eu
assez de temps on a on a manqué de deux
jours pour organiser des matchs de semi
rapide à une période descente c'était
plus pas après la partie aux etats unis
le font sur trois semaines ce qui est un
petit peu un excédent de sens alors moi
je pense que ce filtre à ce type de
tournoi serait plus adapté pour les
championnats du monde et peut-être même
pour une durée un peu moins longtemps
puisque le premier départ avec les
poules
donc les joueurs jours et y construisant
une seule fois au lieu de faire deux
fois avec le problème des tournois des
poules c'est que les parties nulles
sans jouer ce genre de choses des
arrangements en fait peuvent avoir lieu
alors que dans l'élimination directe il
ya c'est vrai qu'il ya des combats
beaucoup plus franc des poules au départ
avec comprend les deux premiers quand
même bon appui après des éliminations en
coupe du monde foot aussi l'histoire en
allemagne autriche en 82 bon par exemple
donc ça existe aussi il ya pas qu aux
échecs c'est vrai et je crois que
nicolas donc on va parler de ses
possibilités donc c'est un hybride aussi
nouvelle formule et tu proposes est
aussi une autre formule pour championnat
du monde parce que ce tournoi de las
vegas et très bien ça a été vraiment
passionnant à suivre il ya eu beaucoup
de surprises
l'année dernière aussi à groningen mais
quand même j'ai un peu la nostalgie des
anciens champions du monde 24 parties
c'était un peu long mais un parti qui ça
durait trois mois dans tous les journaux
les parties publier tous les amateurs
les suivait il y avait une espèce d
analyse de la partie faite par des
millions de joueurs
c'était très intéressant très
passionnant et pour faire des progrès
également donc ayant cette nostalgie
mois déjà une idée de faire par exemple
quatre années de suite les championnats
du monde fis des comme ils ont eu l
des gaz donc désignons peut-être quatre
champions différents avec peut-être des
poules au départ c'est pas et la 5e et
la cinquième année faire une sorte de
super changer le monde avec ses quatre
gagnants des quatre années précédentes
qui fera donc des demi finales et la
finale
s'il ya le même joueur qui a gagné deux
fois ou trois fois je peux y aurait une
façon peut-être de prendre les meilleurs
classements mondiaux pour compléter pour
faire 4 jours c'est parfait disons que
ça pourrait à la fois gardé ce champ
bien du monde nouveau qui est très
intéressant et en même temps tous les
cinq ans c'est peut-être un peu larges
périodes mais à voir ces championnats du
monde où les partis vont séduire très
longtemps mais chaque partie est ultra
analyser et ultra commenter parce que là
le défaut du champion de monde de la
gaspésia c'est quand même que les
parties se sont jouées on a trouvé mer
un très intéressant les résultats mais
les parties en elle même on les a vite
oublié
je pense qu'ils ont va regarder ce soir
mais quand même ça passe très vite on
s'intéressait plus sur le résultat du
match
finalement que la partie russe train ne
pas être rentré dans les détails
c'est vrai aussi alors justement on va
rentrer dans les détails ce soir et loi
parce qu'on va avoir une très jolie
partie oui oui donc une très belle
partie ce soir on a le magicien de la
combinaison actuelle le nouveau talent
des échecs alexei shirov qui inflige une
sévère leçon entre guillemets en fait
qu'ils infligent une très belle partie
l'anglais nigel short vraiment la partie
du championnat
elle a été reconnue par tous les toute
la presse internationale comme étant
prônant la partie la plus spectaculaire
de ce champagne mans 99
alors avant de démarrer cette partie jeu
donc je vous rappelle que d'abord dans
première chose on avait dit comme il ya
une espèce la semaine dernière mais vous
l'avez pas rater puisque vous pouvez
toujours regarder toutes les émissions
diagonale depuis leur commencement en
cliquant sur la partie différée
donc 2
à droite de la page de diagonale différé
et vous aurez ici que la possibilité de
voir toutes les parties il suffit de
cliquer de toutes les émissions
il suffit de cliquer sur le petit bouton
g2 qui est à droite de chacune des
émissions pour faire démarrer la vidéo
correspondante
autre point intéressant pour suivre la
partie avec nous ce soir et pour toutes
les émissions aussi vous avez pour
chacune des émissions un petit bouton à
gauche du texte qui présente donc les
missions qui joue et qui s'appelle jouer
et en cliquant dessus vous arrivez sur
une page qui vous présente un applet
java qui vous permet de regarder la
partie en cliquant et en avançant les
coûts à votre propre rythme d'ailleurs
ça vous permet aussi de voir la partie
du résultat final de voir comment ça
s'est déroulé et peut-être aussi donc de
mieux comprendre les commentaires qui
vont qui vont suivre
voilà donc les lois cette partie n'a que
xl shirov contre nigel short on va
peut-être rappeler que short se fait
éliminer par a écrit chirens et qu'elle
essaye shirov s'est fait éliminer en
quart de finale c'est sciemment 4
mondial rappelons le s'est fait éliminer
en quarts de finale ici p1 ou par la
grande surprise finalement peut-être la
grande surprise de las vegas qui est
dissipée à nous qui a éliminé et loi si
je me rappelle bien ivantchouk ils vont
de shook donc shirov a smile par julie
est alors un joueur un peu moins fort
mais très fort pendant qu'un très beau
parcours en du roumain qui a cessé
c'est pas lui qui je crois que c'est
l'avènement des points d'ici là nous ne
le connaissant pas j'ai demandé à des
joueurs au championnat de france à
jean-marc degraeve s'il le connaît ça il
m'a dit oui il était à
cappelle-la-grande l'année dernière il a
fait cinq points sur neuf
les terminer 230e pas du tout
impressionnant c'était impossible de
deviner avec il ira en finale
1/2 finale des championnats du monde et
il a démontré en tout cas une très belle
très belle rohan autrement regain de
forme en tout cas mais les très jeunes
et très jeunes à 23 il a 25 ans avant
non je crois je crois bien qu'il a 22 ou
23 ans et il est un peu plus haut que
moi je l'avais dans les championnats
jeunes abonde à part le côté là c'est
inattaquable
alors on va démarrer loi cette partie
voilà si on peut vous montrer à la fois
sur la vidéo et je vous rappel sur la
plaie de java dont cliquez sur le bouton
jouer et vous accédez à l'applet java
pour regarder la partie shirov contre
short du championnat du monde de las
vegas c'était un huitième de finale
voilà alors la partie étant assez longue
ou non on va faire comme la dernière
fois on va généraliser la méthode
maintenant nous allons passer des phases
opposition critique on va plus passer
trop de temps sur les premiers coups qui
ont peu les commenter brièvement ici
c'est une défense française comme nigel
short joue depuis très longtemps
donc c'est dans le centre immédiatement
aux blancs puisque l'on n'a pas évité ce
duo thion que je vais tenter la d44 qui
est le rêve de toute ouverture nicolas
je pense comprendre les ouvertures savez
c'est le rêve de voir un classique qui
va occuper le centre mais
toute une frange de joueurs contact de
moderne qui peut faire baisser les prix
au centre ou à l'arrière pour les
attaques pour attaquer l'ennemi de loin
donc des cinq cabanis et trois
troisièmes coude et blanc cassé trois
donc le coût principal je crois que ça
s'appelle la langue steinitz un léger
doute sur sur cette affirmation ne sait
plus loin la marge et alice et si
maintenant les noirs boukari et si c'est
que les blancs pouces immédiatement 1 5
voilà oui exact c'est 2,5 donc ça ça
donne lieu à d'autres d'autres types
d'oppositions
ici donc à l'excès chirurgie ou g5 qui
permet la vente mccutchen si les noirs
veulent jouer tous les quatre
bon c'est une possibilité qui n'est pas
choisie ici là nigel short échanges
allège un peu l'attention centrale en
jouant des prend aux 4 donc on échange
des pièces entre août et a priori pas
une mauvaise chose quand on a quand
l'objectif avoué de la partie et ruineux
le puisque donc dans ce championnat oui
j'en ai beaucoup discuté avec des
collègues au championnat de france dans
un match en deux parties comme on en a
eu là bas
à voir les noirs à la première partie
est un avantage énorme puisqu'on peut
décider de prendre l'initiative
quand même et être agressif avec les
noirs puisqu'on aura toujours la
deuxième avec les blancs pour se
rattraper
alors qu'avec les blancs là
un dérapage est sanctionné puisque si on
perd la première partie avec les blancs
gagné a gagné la deuxième avec les noirs
c'est quasiment impossible
c'est psychologique en fait donc ici
l'objectif donné de chance dans cette
partie était probable en de faire une
partie nulle kelly prend quatre fosses
est donc là l avantage de prix sont
noirs ces cas pas de faiblesses encore
structure parfaite
l'avantagé de la position blanche c'est
qu'ils ont plus d espace je crois que si
c'est la surprise
donc on arrive aux premiers moments
critiques qui prend avec le changé aussi
c'est cool et noir rouge et point m6
encore 6e coup ainsi vous pouvez
positionner votre appel java au 6e coup
mais n'en reprennent avec lyon j'ai donc
là que se recaser 6 le désavantager loi
c'est que ça casse un petit peu la
structure mes pions noirs qui sont moins
harmonieux oui ça casse oui vous voyez
3i l'option gelé les pointes et voilà un
an voilà un deuxième
et voilà le troisième donc trois îles
option c'est moins bien que la structure
blanche maintenant avantage c'est
qu'elle en reprenant du pion on a évité
de perdre la paire de foule et noir ont
de fou alors qu'elles n'ont plus qu'un
et on a obtenu la colonne ouverte ici
j'ai qui va peut-être pouvoir servir
éventuellement à jouer tour j'évite donc
pour envisager de jouer b6 est fourbe et
7 pour commencer à exercer une action
côté rappelons donc ça c'est les
avantages inconvénients il ya foule 26
qui est considéré comme plus solide mais
je connais je m'en rappelle très bien de
la théorie mariage et reprend avec le
fouet par yannis lefrang c'est une
partie très classique c'était fischer
petrossian sur les 300 a pris du plomb
aussi aux matchs des candidats 71
buenos aires qualité de résultats en
fait on gagne celle particules cantine
où il avait joué j'ai trois fois dans
cette position fischer vous avez fait le
cirque et au petrossian qui pourtant
était réputé pour être un joueur très
solide
oui mais il jouait des ouvertures comme
ça avec taux d' espace où il restait sur
d'orange est très attentif biens
canadiens 3 donc développement tout à
fait standard côté blanc pour l'instant
pas trop d' aventure cavaliers 17 pouces
et 4 alors maintenant un problème pour
les noirs dans cette position que faire
du roi au huitième round je rappe et un
huitième poussé quatre alors je sais pas
ce qu'est facturé à gauche ou à droite
ici avec avec le roi noir
alors effectivement la question peut se
poser
si on va à droite a priori ça pas la
très très bon puisque
il semblerait que les pions noirs donc
s'en sont désorganisés de ce côté
puisque le roi pourrait éventuellement
être prise à partie sur cette colonne
ouverte cette colonne j'ai maintenant je
me rappelle de partie des fisher qui
avait invoqué comme ça dans le côté du
côté comme ça ouvert et qui semblerait
que c'était c'est effectivement le bon
coup alors je me méfie je me méfie quand
même d'aider des lois générales mais a
priori effectivement je choisirais mois
plus tôt le grand côté mais il faut dire
que le grand que le grand roque est très
long a effectué une visite inaugurale il
faut jouer au moins quatre coups il faut
sortir les pièces qui gêne il faut
sortir le fou la dame et le fou peut pas
sortir puisque le cavalier le gêne oui
tout à fait donc en fait dans cette
position le gros problème des noirs
c'est qu'ils peuvent pas effectuer le
croire ou dans des conditions décentes
puisque la dame
la dame des vitres sais pas où aller
pour le fou s'est vite c'est assez clair
on va aller en bessette mais si c'est
fou bessette par contre pour la dame des
huit c'est beaucoup plus dur donc les
noirs ou un petit problème de roi dans
cette position alors que pour les blancs
c'est très simple les deux côtés sont
venus petit rock ou alors d'amener de
suite en europe tandis que c'est long et
loire encore une fois c'est parce que la
structure des pions blancs est propre et
donc les pions blancs protège
parfaitement le roi blanc qui se trouve
soit à gauche ou à droite après avoir
croqué
oui et c'est vrai que c'est toujours
plus facile de roke avec quand on
al'avantage de développement on s'expose
moins à une attaque directe donc ici un
coup intéressant
il a choisi de jouer huit c5 retardant
donc le choix du roi
il peut éventuellement encore envisagé
de rock et du grand côté et ils cassent
le centre blanc l'option des cartes ra
un thème qu'on a déjà vu dans des
diagonales aussi pour pour expliquer le
donc la stratégie c'est une contre
attaque centrale profiter les volets
blancs b on remonte patiemment leur
arsenal déjà les noirs essayer leur
poser des questions en mettant leurs
pieds en contact des pions centraux
adverses
oui alors c'est vrai que quand on se
fait étouffer par un adversaire qui
prend le centre c'est terrible puisque
quand on tient le centre on peut aller à
gauche à droite ou au centre
tout est possible donc il faut
absolument éviter de céder complètement
le centre à l'adversaire ou ici ici
c'est clair un c5 c'est une tentative de
deux d'échanger des pions encore au
centre d'ouvrir des colonnes pour
échanger plus de pièces et faire valoir
la paire de fois en finale
c'est un peu plus subtil que prévu mais
je pense que le plan général c'est ça
c'est d'attendre une finale donc shirov
très simple mais ce qu'il peut faire une
suggestion pourquoi il n'a pas avancé un
pion décapant dessin alors donc le coup
d'éclat des cinq peut-être le coup km et
b6 des noirs sort est embêtant il ya
échec un échec
soit qu'ils aient baissé sur youtube et
cinq échecs tout à fait alors peut-être
non c'est non en fait il peut surtout
des cinq échecs sont les siens cachette
food et s'attaque aux ouvriers mais on
se fout des notes donc
bon alors quoi dire des cinq qui avait
b6 bon peut-être que stéphane pas trop
la réputation moi j'ai envisagé plutôt
eu 5 qui m'avait l'air également être
une solution plausible puisque une fois
la position ferme et davantage de
développement des blancs ne sera plus
sentir donc propositions je sais pas et
précisément comment 9eme coup de shearer
finalement un coup logique de
développement petit rock et finalement 1
nigel short mais choisit lui aussi
maintenant de déjouer le catalogue de
jouets aussi le petit rocks qui mêle les
rois de vos positions a priori donc
excentré dans moins dangereuses mais les
tourangeaux restent à chartes de
problème en fait à sa position
probablement c'est de voir sa structure
nos pions un peu déficiente et sont fous
ces huit aussi cas pour l'instant du mal
à voir son avenir tout de suite
éclaircies oui c'est même l'ensemble des
pièces noires en fait qui qui patauge un
peu là on sait pas trop le cavalier 17
est pour l'instant muselé par le pion
ici vous voyez cas ces cinq lots 5 sont
contrôlés le fou c'est vital en lui il
est mûr et c'est très simple et les
blancs ont un avantage de développement
considérable il inclut 15 juin coûte
dame déjà ils ont les tout relié plus
les perspectives d' attaque comme tu
disais stéphane donc ici avantage blanc
certains dans cette position maintenant
il faut voir que sur le long terme
les noirs pour reprendre l'avantagé
grâce à la paire de flou mais enfin
c'est vraiment du très longtemps alors
on va voir ce qui se passe tournons donc
logique à une fois qu'on a fait le roc
la tour est un jeu on la met au centre
tours centre sur les principes général
cabinet v6 alors calmé 6 c'est tout de
suite à l'intérêt d'attaquer le fouet de
libérer éventuellement une case pour son
propre fou qui pourra sortir sur la
classe 17 money un autre intérêt aussi
c'est donc ça ouvert la ligne là ça a
mis un vis-à-vis entre les deux dames la
dame blanche et ada noir et que
l'échangé évidemment clairement
favorable pour les noirs puisque quand
on échange les dames il ya plus trop d'
attaque sur le roi comme les noirs
epyon devant loin c'est l'objectif dans
cette position bon mais alors shirov
s'était aménagé la casse pour le fou ces
quatre ans revient donc en f1 mon
position voilà puis on prend des quatre
qu'elle les prend des quatre tout à fait
normal
et là on voit deux cavaliers à
s'émerveiller de stéphane lessard de
calais 110 des yeux brillants d'autres
cavaliers qui rayonne depuis ce qu'ils
ont ils sont au centre ils ont un char
l'action qui va jusque dans le camp
ennemi et donc qu'il crée des tensions
potentiellement dangereuses et empire
fut une sorte de périmètre de sécurité
qui a été établie ici ça serait bien que
donc enfin de l'idée d'un short et de
jouer évidemment dans cette position aux
6,5 pour chasser le cavalier et échanger
les dames
alors de quoi at il eu peur exactement
je pense de cavani v5 avec la casse des
six qui arriverait qu'il tomberait sous
contrôle d'un cavalier
une fois qu'on est en d6 alors ya 17 ans
prise il y avait cinq donc 5 n'était pas
possible tout de suite
est-ce qu'il n'aurait pas sacrifié par
d'un match 5
on va rendre à voir ce qui se fait donc
déjà joué un coup dont qui arrive à ce
genre de position le roi était sur une
colonne ouverte donc les a pas de purs
devant lui pour le protéger
donc il se met derrière en pions en tête
qu'il protège et en même temps ils
doivent se donne la possibilité de
mettre lui même une tour sur sa case
j'ai vite pour contrôler des cases
sur une colonne verte en fait et donc
disons courage suite pour généraliser ce
que tu veux dire c'est un couple
prophylactique voire même qui peut
s'intégrer dans un plan d'attaqué des
rois blanc n'est de toute façon c'est un
bon coup le roi lion à schwyz
quand g8 c'est une certitude bon alors
là oui c'est 3 maintenant c'est le sait
le signe le signe de l'attaqué donné le
but de sio et de deux derniers coups
donc ces trois défendeurs qui est des
cartes quand on est 13e coup je rappelle
qu'on est au 13e coup le coup ces trois
protège le cavalier en d4 et donc permet
à la dame blanche de se libérer de la
défense de ce cavalier
voyez donc de ce jaillir en h5 ou là
elle exerce une pression terrible sur le
sur le roi puisque la tacle pions h7 le
pion à vii dont qui empêchera tout rejet
mythe et on peut voir éventuellement des
manoeuvres de tourcom sa honda tours 1 1
3 et 1 3 pour attaquer avec la dame là
des monstres qui a quand même le mérite
d'être totalement indélogeable par des
moyens légaux
donc
donc forte menace notre réaction rapide
de nigel short qui jouent eux 5
et là pas de pas de soucie pas de bluff
bloc bluff nigel d'un match 5 quand même
bon line 30 tactique alors je vais vous
la comme j'ai analysé ce à la maison je
peux vous expliquer rapidement si on
prend des 4 donc on va jouer dans les
rentes sur l'échiquier donc on est au
14e coup et on a quatorze couples et
blanc les blancs a priori sacrifie un
cavalier et avec la dame en h5 commença
à monter
une batterie de pièces contre le roi et
demi sachant que c'est pas grave de
perdre du matériau si on arrive à
prendre le roi puisque le but du jeu est
effectivement et de mettre échec et mat
le roi vous plus que tout alors on va
montrer le vendre sur l'échiquier donc
après pions prend ici suivre et à mon
avis cavaliers ponction et six
magnifiques menace d'un proche 7 matin
on va lever le pointer d'un proche cet
échec et note fouquereau f6 et
maintenant fou détroit le fou donc qui
était en feu se réveille et on voit que
effectivement des 3 l'a menacé d'un
projet cet échec et mat imparable
totalement valable taurian interposé
devant l'idée de sortir le cavalier
s'est libéré la fois la diagonale est
aussi sur la case f6 d'empêcher le pion
à f7 devenir intercepté le fou
maintenant qui tentent d 3 voilà donc un
joli thème géométriques
donc nous revenons l'opposition donc
finalement un aïeul joue le coup
cavaliers en d5 occasion des cinq
maintenant sur cavani pour 9,6 bien
entendu il y aurait cavaliers 25.46
attaquant la dame défendre achète donc
le cavalier b6 un peu excentré revient
et occupe une position au centre
largement appel dans des anciens
entraîneurs non gilbert grimbert qui me
disait quand les cavaliers se croisent
au son la position devient
incroyablement complexe ici c'est un peu
simple le cas ça va voler donc là on a
trois quarts y est aussi en train
nicolas fraxinelle position le l'idée de
chiroque de sacrifier non pas un mais
finalement deux cavaliers sa son idée
c'est ça les a aimés de cavalli est très
original
toute la beauté d'apposition blanche ses
rangs deux coups qui part en fumée
et finalement c'est la pièce qu'on
attende ans qui vient qui vient mater
c'est une variante assez esthétique
en tout cas est ici alors surprise
shirov dit très serein très soul 1 le
letton très sereine et en ramène une
pièce de plus vers le centre on
ad'autres tour placé maintenant sur des
colonnes splendide au centre de carrier
au centre est un fou fn qui ne demande
qu'à sortir au moment opportun
oui le seul problème est que une dame h5
aussi qui attaquent le seul ennui et en
cette pièce cavaliers le carillon des
quatre qui est en prise par le pion aux
oui donc ici objet de prendre pour nigel
short
sinon sinon cette position ne ressemble
plus à rien du tout il a déjà tous les
désavantages donc là il est obligé de
prendre la pièce ce qui fait qu'on prend
des 4 donc ça veut dire que la nageuse
sorte dans une pièce donc il peut avoir
l'espoir de rendre cette pièce plus tard
pour pour arrêter la patte blanche
oui mon avis ça peut être une des idées
enfin le l'idée principale de prendre
une pièce sont en général pas de la
rendre d'ailleurs stéphane may mais de
la garder oui c'est qu'ils voient pas
les justifications du shirov pour cette
pièce puisque l'idée de faire cavalier
propre ne marche plus donc short qui
prend le cavalier nous disons l'attaqué
n'est pas sérieuse ah oui mais ici les
gens maintenant ça va être très jolie
puisque tous les prochains coups ils
savent être du harcèlement pure et
simple et nadja le chanteur jouer les
uniques défense à chaque fois donc tu
reprends des 4 c'est vrai ce qu'avaient
les prendre ces menaces dont hervé
nyatto ce qui arrivait ce carnet tout
cas être attaqué par la tour qui est
donc attaquer et par l'adam qui voient
là c'est la dame h5 qui fait une action
formidable puisque l attaque à la fois
le roi est sous pression adverse
hélas quand même une tenant désormais
une action vers le centre et oui oui
mais y est le plus important en fait
dans cette pression c'est ce clouage que
j'ai pointé avec une flèche jaune la
tour blanche qui vient sur la dame noire
un peu loin je ne tombe donc on est
short m'arrivera pas se débarrasser qui
veulent leur seul et tout temps il ya
plus de n'y a pas d'échappatoire à
priori donc là le coup f5 est très
logique
est ce qu'ils pouvaient pas tenté
cavaliers f4 et un voilier f 4 jours une
proposition de nicolas donc la preuve
nigel short michaud carrière cadrée
saddam emprise me attaque lui-même la
dame blanche
on peut supposer que la dame blanche
pourrait échapper
nous disons à cette attaque en jouant
par exemple je sais pas la dame sur la
case h4 attaqué lui même le cavalier et
laissant la dame de la jeune chanteuse
prise mais alors la dame noire vient
d'annoncer cette dans la dame h théâtre
donne c7 est peut-être le coup cavaliers
prend un siège et 136 avec away moulin
de menaces voire même voir devenir voit
la menace de mme a et si les noirs
prennent un échec
d'abord en reprenant la pièce est
ensuite on reprend des cavaliers maus
est convaincant donc proposition
mirifique active 13,5 à mon avis et elle
se retrouve effectivement dans cette
position elle sait quel avantage donc la
loi
d'intercepter l'action de la dame et en
plus attaque le cavalier et attaque le
cavalier d'alexei shirov qui vient donc
en g3 alors là un thème récurrent dans
l'émission des gones al stéphane c'est
le cavalier kasparov
le cavaly caspar et cavani kasparov donc
ici la case f5 en l'occurrence accès
direct avec le cavalier vers la thèse
s511 bien les classes part of a dit
voilà un jour quand j'ai un cavalier
bref cinq contre un petit rock ça vaut
un pion voilà bon alors ici dans une
pièce de moins mais un câble innocent
que ça ferait quand même plaisir il
était craint que les noirs pourrait
prendre ce quartier avec leur fou donc
son cavalier ne serait pas un poison
permanent
c'est vrai l'autre bon la menace
principale étant quand même de jouer
pour eux ont des seins à mon avis qui
gagnerait le cavalier de c3 et xsara
peut-être sinon c'est trop s'écarter
plus compliqué c'est plus qu'aubry non
c'est pas plus à cause de kapsys
toxicologue peut-être en arrière dans
une version améliorée elle tout à fait
donc harcèlement de toute façon des de
la tour puisque le fou cet été encore en
prise avec la tour
mais est-ce que c'est pas risquer ce qui
laisse pas la tour passé landes alors
sur le tour en le contrôle mais tout
aussi la tour venait là il y aura
simplement qu'elle dit et six attaquants
la dame et protégeant la cage dynamique
avis occupe marque forte et c'est la
cardio sensible mais contrôlerait et
contrôlerait tout en fait dans cette
position donc il faut pas laisser les
répartir
c'est le clouage qui est capital dans
cette position il faut rester sur le
clouage tour d2 l avantage de défendre
aussi l'option f2 qui peut devenir un
pro non sensibles
d'ailleurs d'un v6 alors là il se
débarrasse du clonage n'apportent
finalement on voit assez facilement que
tourcoing kabadio 5 donc ici une fois de
plus c'est une variante ce n'est pas la
partie
donc si on est au niveau design 19e coup
et en rappel et loire 10e coup donc
c'est un exemple de
ce qui pourrait se passer donc surtout
reprend cavaliers y aurait fonds f2i
échec le roi sera obligé de partir en h1
et la foux prend tour ici c'est plus une
pièce de plus mais une tour de plus
qu'on aurait et sans réelle contre
chance d' attaque donc totalement
inacceptable lecavalier n'est pas en
prise ce qu'il faut voir aussi avec le
goût dame b6 sait qu'elle peut revenir
vers g6 pourparlers monal peut aussi
voilà elle peut aussi la possibilité de
défense assez forte la dame noire aussi
fait qu'il pourrait revenir en défense
oui oui c'est vrai c'est un coup en fait
polyvalence des clowns cavaliers ça
revient à la défense y aura donc un coût
qui a l'air assez parfait alors là un
coup sûr prenait un avc shirov puisque
sa dame qui faisait pression contre le
roi des airs ce matin et loi va revenir
au 19e coup sûr la case o2 effectivement
c'est pas un coup positionnelle c'est
plutôt un coup tactique puisque la
menace c'est de prendre le cavalier mais
est-ce que c'est pas un aveu d'échec de
la tacc nous aimer et on va voir
disons qu'il est bien de pointer là on a
l'impression que finalement ça n'a pas
marché et qui revient en arrière alors
oui maintenant vers organisé mais
l'enjeu de la position n'est plus la
taxe sur le roi puisque cette attaque a
échoué on peut le dire avec le retour de
la dame noire sur 7 comme sur cette
troisième traverse l'accession fait de
combiner et pas une attaque à l'autre en
face d'un thème à l'autre voilà de l'
attaque purement positionnelle sur le
roi sur le long terme au concret alors
ici forcé de bouger le cavalier pour
voilà le problème à ce car il est
attaqué voilà qualifiant réussissent
donc 19e coulée noire
finalement donc enlève le cavalier de la
prise de la torah ans les six maintenant
dame ou 5
alors encore une menace directe ici on
menace jadis m'ont dit qu'ils allaient
g3 wave est alors déjà peut-être et
loire un scoop tête on peut noter que
alexei donc a fait une banque une
pression sur une pression surtout sur
les pièces de dice est sûre il n'y
aurait peut-être pu jouer au lieu de
cooldown 5la moi j'avais le sentiment
qu'ils pouvaient jaune possible b2b 4
qui al'air embêtant puisque le fou a pas
beaucoup de cases en fait on se rend
compte
voyez b2b 4 c'est une possibilité
intéressante mais ça permettrait de
foulpointe deux avec arrivée dans une
finale avec égalité matérielle qui
serait donc d'emblée pas clair en fait
il a vu qu'il avait beaucoup plus fort
dans cette position ce qu'il a joué
c'est à dire d'abord la dame aux cinq
donc là quand j'ai vu que j'étais en
train d'expliquer la menace a tant
qu'allié h5 il faut jouer et roire j'ai
vite ce que fait ce qu'on fait nigel
short au 20e coup en 20e courage évite
donc pour empêcher
le clouage en fait et orages de cavalli
wipe là et maintenant alors c'est très
joli sur b4 donc on va encore mentionné
donc c'est encore une variante on est au
20e coup les noirs viennent de jouer
roger vite sur b4 donc c'est vrai une
fois de plus fou pont avec 2.2 semble
tout à fait logique et maintenant d'un
moucheron tour échec au roi donc
importer fils de dames ponctuel très
très ponctuel stéphane un pseudo
sacrifice où le psg qui a bien récupéré
la dame et les noirs terminé avec une
qualité de plus donc dans une qualité
une tour contre une pièce mineurs avec
donc un gain a priori facile en fait un
gain un gain facile oui d'autant plus
qu'on en finale il ya plus de il ya plus
trop de soucis techniques donc pardon il
faut lui combinaison une pointe de new
york était un petit piège en fait c'est
le loyer c'est une sorte de petit piège
et là ce qui très joli à los angeles ou
coup j'ai vraiment j'ai craqué pour pour
ce 21e coût des blancs h2 h3 en pleine
tempête en pleine tempête tempête du
désert joue h2 h3 vraiment le coup le
plus tranquille donc lui même l'idée
simple et d'empêcher ce coup cavaliers
chez g4s enfin font preuve de d'abord et
g4 après et les noirs se retrouve dans
une situation horrible où ils ont plus
de plus de coups le coût de
développement normal aurait été fou 6,2
fois réussi six ne peut pas puisque le
cavalier ci s'est pas défendu et surtout
17 qui aurait également b2b 4
vous fondez cette sueur et b2b 4 par
exemple et puis c'est tout yaya toure a
eu 8 est assez voire des tours à huit
noms mais je note peut être rectifiées
ma remarque
ouais food et cette possibilité
intéressante que je n'ai pas envisagé
peut-être peut-être fou 17 tout
simplement moi je propose rien du tout
en fait je pensais à une idée mais sa
part de marché au-dessus devant message
est trop long de ce trajet envisage
effectivement tout reprend 17 mai mais
sa part de marché tout de suite avec
vient de prendre avec nous de prendre
avec le cavalier à f/5 enfin de créer
des menaces mais c'est pas un terme et
attaquer donc vous voyez mon fou 17 al
orabi avis aux amateurs de l'internet
envoyez nous vos mails 0 marque vous
pouvez nous trouver dans kontakt pas de
réponse évidente en tout cas donné ce
soir donc le 17 on propose aux cavaliers
car allez peut-être cavaliers pros f5
tout simplement
c'est peut-être le coup b2b car
l'organisation une forte attaque
peut-être b2b 4 est intéressant b2b
quatre façons à tour eu huit semaines à
venir de réfuter mai à tours à huit
dames prend un nom ça marche pas stephen
toutefois je m'en fous moi non la
question des n'est apparemment pas si
évidente peut-être les pointes 5
effectivement nicolas t'as donné une
bonne piste
en tout cas la position et est ouverte
aux analyses ici nigel short choisi de
jouer tour vite immédiatement permettant
à chéraute de sacrifier encore
ouais le désavantage est temps que les
tours ne sont pas liés d'où l'intérêt de
lier les tours c'est que cette tourner
défendu que par le cavalier alors que si
le fou ces huit avaient pu sortir il a
d'abord eu une action plus importante
que sur sa case de départ
mais les tourelles même se protègeraient
l'une l'autre oui ce qui retient ce qui
aurait d'ailleurs évité le coude et
l'excellent shirov qui simplifie la dame
pas de souci donc là c'est le problème
de développement n'est noir finalement
preuve de développement des noirs si oui
oui oui on peut dire ça c'est des
problèmes qui avait plus vraiment de
coup de coûts intéressants et la menace
était b2b 4 donc ici séquence fort c'est
qu'avec des programmes 23 tout reprendre
à tourcoing cavaliers courant jet set et
là le coup tant attendu arrive enfin
b2b quatre maisons les questions au fou
c5 qui n'a pas beaucoup de cases qui n'a
pas beaucoup de choses mais tout à fait
vrai d'autant plus qu'il a envie de
rester sur quand même sur cette
diagonale qui et qui est dirigé vers le
roi voilà on va la pointe est quand même
c c'est une très belle diagonale qui
pointe sur ce pion f2 on aurait bien
aimé rester là maintenant on peut pas
partir ailleurs sur x fuite aurait
cavaliers h5 échec entre autres voir
même tour 2e mi temps là avec avec une
pression terrible terrible donc choix
d'hommes c6 et 25e coup des blancs tout
exercice qui donc attaquer la tour 8es
maintenant un deuxième tour entre dans
le camp adverse
ces deux tours en fait maintenant
empêche les noirs par exemple de sortir
leur flou superbe sous peine de perdre
leur tour à 8 qui pour l'instant n'a pas
encore joué et c'est de tout aussi
peuvent maintenant faire des échecs or
on adhère sofa c'est une menace terrible
non tout à fait le contrôle de l'amitié
manger dans en tout cas dans cette
pression aussi important que le contrôle
de la de la 7e les tours les tours
blanches sont vraiment merveilleux this
year mon avis la position déjà gagnante
pour les blancs jeu
je pense pas trop me tromper en disant
ça fout b6 attaque la tour on va pointer
ça attaque 7 tours là qui n'a plus de
cases sur l'amitié à manger donc on
intercale un petit échec donc l'échec au
roi déjà c'est un problème pour les
noirs il n'y a pas beaucoup de coups
pour le roi m m 2 y en a 2 il ya f6 ou
h6 donc h6 s'est fait un peu je sais pas
trop comment dire mais un peu stricte
c'est une expression de backgammon qui
veut dire qu'on n'est pas loin du mathan
gars commencent à faire pour étouffer
complètement sur la bande
évidemment d'ailleurs j'ai trouvé la
variance déchu tente alors je vais la
montrer parce qu'il est joli nom croit
h6 alors imagine la première solution
pour les noirs vols à roissy ce donc on
est au 26e coup des noirs après le
coutour g8 échec avec les chiffres en
fait une pression donc sur le corner
adverse mais une solution pour les noirs
c'est de mettre le roi sur la case h6 et
la tour prends c'est vite et donc sur
tours france évite donc maintenant tout
reprend fou natalité après tout reprend
fou il ya ma tante de coûts qui avait
les preuves cinq échecs
rush 5 forcé et là on finit avec jets
d'eau g4g de g4 ou même le fou aussi
aurait pu faire maintes le fourré pu
faire le faire également
donc ici
réfutation assez joli de 0 à 6 donc tout
logiquement de we do right is donc tout
logiquement neige elle chante bien quand
même là où il ya des cases
c'est à dire on assiste mellal attaques
continues le harcèlement harcèlement
continu cavaliers h5 échec le roi noir
sévèrement malmené dans cette position
cc oui c'est souvent nicolas dans les
attaques contre le roi une suite
d'échecs comme ça qui crée un
déséquilibre qui crée le matilda nos
matériels les suites fort sentent on va
dire on l'avantagent donc de mettre
l'adversaire sur des rails unix en voie
de dégagement alors si ça amène un gars
force et on gagne
si elle ferme nt1 gains matériels ou un
mat on gagne la partie
et là il y avait finalement une seule
variante envisagé c'était 3 à 6
autrement ça fait quatre coups que les
couloirs sont forcés ouais ouais tout à
fait ou alors ici maintenant aussi
s'efforcer 1
c'est plus ou moins forcé enfin il ya
des varois d assez compliqué dans le set
se revoir au cette réunion le 5 mai il
ya pas match immédiat par tour des huit
tours dévit tours 8
j'ai eu une plongée 8h allongée de huit
échecs et doit de gérer 6 1 le food &
cie quelle force qu'il peut le foot peut
sortir
en fait nous faut pas oublier que le
foot peut sortir ce qui permettrait de
mettre en jeu égal mais si nous nous
saurons nicolas on perd aussi enfin et
loire on perd aussi la tour si tout ça
on peut aussi la tour mais de toute
façon cette tour
est condamné c'est le roi en 5 alors que
nokia déjà que ce roi est malade et il
se retrouve presque ans et demi donc
sous le feu de toutes les pièces
blanches malgré que les blancs données
lordan ils ont sacrifié leurs dames oui
non mais les pièces blanches sont très
très efficace dans cette position est en
outre la dame noire on sait si ce n'est
pas très efficace puisqu'elle à venir
attaquer alors une dame tout seul ça
marche pas très bien en général il faut
être fort heureusement qu'elle soit
soutenue par d'autres pièces ou alors
qu'elle soit face à un roi faible
lorsque vous dans cette attaque et loi
aussi c'est que deux tours a priori et
nicholas avoue une dame
reste qu'à rallier fou contre de fou
résultat les noirs ont quand même un
avantage potentiellement
oui mais rien à ce matériel d'une tour
c'est une situation typique dans
laquelle la comptabilité est absurde
parce que qu'est ce qui compte c'est le
roi noir est en plein milieu des
fichiers sur le choix des pièces et demi
donc on peut pas à raisonner en termes
matériels
évidemment si la taxe arrêtait qui est
un trop grand déséquilibre matériel vélo
a regagné om là c'est pas le cas
d'attaqué le plus belle et on va gagner
à coup sûr la tour en 1 8 ou le fut
ensuite puisque pour parer les échecs
froid les noirs sont obligés de laisser
la tour android apparemment a
effectivement on va voir ce qui se passe
effectivement ne sont pas rapportés aux
trois c'est une sorte d'espoir autour
des 3 28e coup des blancs alors qu'ils
auraient pu gagner une tour j'aurais pu
gagner le tour il préfère jouer ça qui
menacent quoi alors ça c'est menaces
justement renault à mon avis c'est ça
qui est beau dans cette position c'est
que les noirs ne peuvent rien faire du
tout non non pas de coûts ces gens ne
peuvent rien dire une coquille on dirait
que c'est pas voir - lecouls qui a été
loué s'assemble ça c'est incroyablement
risqué parce que l envers vacances en
rien menacée mais on a défendu sur ces
trois ce qui est déjà un avantage et les
noirs n'ont pas vraiment de constructif
dans cette position donc il joue un
coupe d'arbres qui est la seule pièce
inactivé joue damage six attaquants
cavani h5 cherchons un peu déstabilisé
les pièces blanches sur quoi réponse
tranquille quand même fou meurtrier mais
en fait à l'excellent n'est pas pressé
il est un tour de moins enfin le
l'équivalent d'une tour de moins enfin
s'il d'armes contre une tour mais
défoncez pièces jonchant les attaques et
défenses fils quand on est attaqué en
fait il n'est pas possible puisque les
noirs sont ficelés en fait complètement
ficelé dames série chaix ça gesticule un
peu de côté noir donc ici il faut pas
jouer les rouages deux à cause de foot -
f2 qui donnerait quand même mieux un
contrôle au sérieux donc si je tourne et
un perdant le pion c3 mais obtenant en
compensation l'activité pour ce fou donc
f1 qui repassait en f3 menace note est
mal assis menace note effectivement
nicolas puisqu'il menace tour des cinq
échecs et mat
non pas tout de suite non mais attends
bien encore la corde au cou oui il y en
a sur des beats d'abord food et 6 et
tour de cinq matches voilà exactement
c'est plus précis donc ici un film avec
cluj donc là un maillage receipts tour
des cinq échecs d'abord enfin lien la
manade ton détroit avec ses chiens
c'était en fait pour activer ce fou
finalement c'est les noirs ayant
tellement peu de choses à faire ils sont
déjà de perdre du temps le temps qu'on
active le fouet et c'est fini donc ici
la position est finie donc vous voyez il
échoue au cices capitulation complète
puisque maintenant après tout reprend
tour
les blancs ont égalisé le matériel
conservent toutes leurs chances d'attac
qui égalise et loire avec quand même une
différence de qualité de matériel
puisque ces deux tours contre une dame
on dit souvent d'ailleurs une autre sont
qu'une puissante nicolas que deux dames
surtout de nos positions ouvertes
oui où les tours des colonnes
et traverse occupé mais là quand même
c'est le parti s'est arrêté là non non
non je me semble que les noirs peuvent
encore lutter notamment f2 je crois que
nigel short n'est pas encore résigné et
tout peut encore arriver puisque on
n'est pas à l'abri d'abord d'une erreur
d'une erreur de calcul
donc tout est encore possible - et puis
si on regarde le matériel est illégale
et maintenant les menaces sur le roi
noir ont un peu un peu disparu non ou
pas tout à fait en commun on peut on
peut très bien envisager
on va voir comment comment la partie se
déroule voyons d'un pro b 4 donc en tout
cas on en sait plus on est un nouvelle
phase de la partie les blancs récupérer
leur matériel l'euro n'en est toujours
en danger mais un petit peu moindre tout
à l'heure et en fait c'est une lutte de
matériel disons hétérogènes entre deux
tours contre une dame et puis des pièces
de blanchet en robe noire
mal situés oui là il aurait pu peut-être
attaqué vers le pire est devant finalisé
tour vite alors là on arrive dans la
fameuse menace 30 20e coup 33e coudes
pour 8 pour vider blanc menace tour des
cinq échecs et mat je vais le pointer
quand même j'ai pas pourquoi je dis
quand même mais je le prends acte
voilà voilà menacé le match puisque le
fou des six est cloué ne peut pas lui
même prendre la tour sous peine de ce
lieu l'échec de l'autre tour bien que
par une seule parade food et 4 été forcé
donc alexei shirov jeu tour des huit
attaquants de le fou maintenant de
repartir ou il est elle qui repart où il
était à 3 c'est une diversion c'est pour
obtenir la case 1
ah oui c'est à dire ceux d'un pont à 3
il y aurait toujours un échec est
pratiquement mat
un match à suivre ah oui la dame s'est
mis d'accord c'est si la dame contrôler
la case eu un chat la dame noire examen
à 5 ou d'hommes ces trois là le contrôle
à cazaux un essai ce coût est fait pour
faire diversion ne peut pas quitter la
diagonale fléché donc damas 5 est
maintenant très jolie tourne vite des
deux réitérant la menace puisque là il
ya interceptions 2 interceptions des
gones en fait c'est là qu'on voit que le
renard est vraiment le mal placé
puisqu'il toujours sous la menace d'un
match à cause de ce cavalier h5 qui
contrôlent des cases très sensible c'est
oui c'est intéressant de voir un
cavalier excentré qui jouent un rôle
déterminant dans l'attaqué pour une fois
puisqu'il empêche le roi noir de partir
vers la droite et donc son roi noir est
susceptible d'être se faire mater au
centre dont il est obligé de pousser les
pions et le sol est que je suis le seul
coup des quatre seul coup pour parer aux
36e coup donc et noir jouent aux cartes
qui libère une case de fuite pour le roi
noir
cette réception la case f5 et
l'accessoire et occupe cette case mais
avec son fou donc il empêche les numéros
en noir en boîte en fait c'est une sorte
de mise en boîte c'est exactement ça
exactement
donc la foux c4 alors sa part pas la
meuse tout
ça parle la menace plus ou moins
jusqu'après tour où elle joue fou aux 3
donc la position assez curieuse au dr
échec foulhac série donc sacrifie son
fou mais à la d'artagnan tour voilà
clatot honte à dire que sur pions prend
fou la dame se venge sur la tour d2 ou
alors l'inconvénient c'est qu'il ya un
coût très simple dans cette position
c'est tour dé d1 qui conserve le clouage
et donc à terme va gagner ce fou outre s
étonnant les coûts nous trouvera les
petits coups de tours d'alexei dans
cette partie avec le tour des trois qui
étaient un peu curieux maintenant des
petits coups de tous comme ça il
attaquera noir du fond puis après 2
devant un peu de tous les côtés c'est
curieux four b3 tourbe et un très simple
on continue à défendre la tour en
maintenant ses gagnants c'est nigel
short qui doit chercher à démontrer
qu'il peut casser l'harmonie blanchi un
gain matériel maintenant pour les blancs
en fait vous ces deux tours b 4 alors là
c'est très joli
puisque après d'un point à 3 y aurait
tout reprend pions et ça s'entend plus
1,5 et le flou des trois serait
complètement de prix sans avec toutes
les pièces blanches protéger donc ici
les derniers soubresauts de nigel short
f5 fouet trois ils n'arrivent pas à
changer fondamentalement la position
faut aux 4 et maintenant c'est l'heure
de prendre le fou qui vient de se
déclarer
si on prend 2,3 ça y est les blancs
ville étaient à égalité matérielle
maintenant ils viennent de récupérer
sont virtuellement une pièce de plus ils
ont virtuellement une pièce de plus en
gardant tous leurs atouts
c'est à dire le roi noir faible donc là
la fin on va passer assez rapidement
dessus puisqu'elle ne présente plus un
gros intérêt une fois que
l'investissement matériel est revenu
donc on regarde quand même fou prend f3
gf3 en 40 ans 44e coup donc je prends un
f3 la position c'est quasiment aplani
alors après le coup des noirs dame rang
puis on en a trois
le cavaly revient il a fait son travail
qu'elle est encore une finesse il
revient tu as des preuves 4 sur des
retours nicolas
voilà donc là tout vu nicolas vue si les
noirs prôner la tour maintenant en d4
les termes allié fort est un échec sur
la case aux trois et ensuite prendre la
dame avec ce qu'on appelle une
fourchette d'une très jolie fourchette
voilà donc la suite b6 tour des quatre
dans cette position il abandonne on sait
pas pourquoi il a choisi ce moment là
exactement pour abandonner puisque a pas
de menaces directes mais la position a
perdu toute façon tout cas on peut
supposer que les blancs ou même peut
très vite créé des menaces de maths
encore une fois un contre le roi noir et
même récupéré en fait les pions noirs
avec une impossible pour la dame en fait
d'attaquer des pièces blanches sur tout
autour qui se protègent l'autre en fait
c'est l'avantagé ici c'est comme une
dame un peu démultiplier les colonnes de
tours mais deux tours plus un cavalier
tous un cavalier bien sûr ça fait un
effet contrôler tous les restes at her
non mais en faite le
ce qui est déterminant dans cette
position sécrétions à 7 et b6 des noirs
sont beaucoup trop loin de la promotion
donc pas de dangereux du tout et c'est
les blancs qui vont mettre en premier
des menaces sur le tapis ça qu'il a joué
à peu près 90% de la partie avec du
matériel en moins chez rough
il ya juste les trois ou quatre derniers
coups c'est lui qui s'est dit qu'elle
serve son matériel de plus c'est juste
un qui dit et je gagne alors en tout cas
on avait bien une partie d'un style de
chiron c'est vraiment un attaquant hors
pair ressent nulle part on s'ennuie pas
et il a toujours des coups qui sont
vraiment surprenants et je crois qu'on
peut dire c'est vous ré véritable
héritier de quelqu'un que tu connais
bien
nicolas c'est le magicien de riga c'est
le style romantique ce qu'on appelle
faire des sacrifices spéculatifs
on n'est pas certain que ça marche mais
je joue la tac je sacrifie voilà
complètement intuitif c'est le jeu
enthousiaste et romantique le style
romantique
donc on malgré cette jolie victoire est
la victoire en matchs dont contre chir
contre short donc avec ces chiffres se
fait éliminé ensuite en quarts de finale
par la révélation du tournoi donc on en
a parlé tout à l'heure le roumain nice
ip à nous et qui lui même qu'il a fait
un brillant tour main mais ce que je
voulais dire c'est qu'il dissipe et un
nou contre shirov subi une attaque
terrible de shiro j'ai passé 27 parties
complètement les vases une défense car
au cas où il a résisté c'est ça qui est
étonnant qu'elle sang-froid et la lazio
les deux parties donné six pianos shirov
son son extraordinaire ces sacrifices à
tout va dans tous les sens et il arrive
à tenir avec un sang froid remarquable
non mais il est très respecté en
roumanie 6 p à nous tous les joueurs
roumains le considère comme étant très
fort et il a travaillé vraiment beaucoup
pour ce championnat du monde et s'est
entraînée ils sont fermés celle mise au
point dans une sorte de cave refuge et
je dirais donc il s'entraîne et six mois
avant il a fait
travailler très très sérieusement pour
sa gouverne que khalifa le sortir de sa
cave le faire venir ici qui nous
expliquent les roumains général parle
français et femmes ouais et donc je
pense midi c'était à nous viendrait nous
raconter son championnat b je crois
qu'on va essayer mais cher on va essayer
d'inviter dont on va essayer de voir si
on va l'appeler et puis on va voir s'il
est disponible je crois que ce serait
comme invité magnifique voilà je crois
qu'on va pas se gêner on va essayer
aussi d'avoir alexander kalichman pour
cette émission donc dire merci à nicolet
le passé
plaisir était pour moi et donc mais faut
pas hésiter évidemment revenir et on
saura que ce qu'on peut dire non
je crois est loin on va être au match
bac robin haase qui lie la semaine
prochaine donc très belles images on en
reparlera puisque
vendredi donc on en reparlera on va
aller ensuite samedi et dimanche donc
voir ce très beau match bacrot cela ce
qu'ils ont essayé de récupérer des
images et on va aussi aller à paris ou
au jardin du luxembourg puisque le sénat
français fait une
une présentation d'un espace échec à
côté du sénat c'est la grande tradition
le jardin du luxembourg est l'endroit où
se retrouvent tous les joueurs d'échecs
donc si j'ai bien compris le l'idée
c'est d'installer des nouvelles tables
pour les joueurs d'échecs donc dans ce
jardin des tables en marbre en fait oui
donc des tables qui résiste au temps
voilà donc à côté du sénat et une
cérémonie avec des personnalités qui
viennent pour honorer ce nouvel espace
est chic n est pas du luxembourg donc on
ira puisqu'il va y avoir du monde et on
reparlera et on en reparlera voilà donc
je vous dis merci d'avoir suivi cette
émission avec nous et donc bay la
semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
émission diagonale